the white pieces here we go here we go
and magnus wow he starts with one g3 uh
not what we're used to seeing from him
not occupying the center but he's
freestyling the world champion he's
played this before in the tour and okay
with his last move he goes back into
more well-known territory
the reti opening and uh here we see both
sides finally starting to take control
off
is it a little bit like one b3 it's
exactly the same idea just on the other
side uh kind of mirror image white's
whole idea by pushing the g pawn forward
is to create a nice home for the white
bishop and look how black has played
copycat a fiance for black as well
both sides are about to put their
bishops on the longest diagonals but
this last move by jordan is very very
rare
normally black there brought out the
light squared bishop that would have
gone into what we call the chigarin
opening
and uh okay magnus just taking a pause
will he push a pawn will he bring white
slight squad bishop out to that nice
hole on fiance on g2
simon are you surprised by this opening
choice by either side
a little bit surprised yeah i mean not
not so much for magnus because uh he he
kind of played this way in the world
championships as i know you're aware
because you've had this kind of opening
set up but uh
jordan playing this last move is as you
say
a bit odd uh because you're gonna move
your bishop and one of the long-term
problems black can have in this kind of
structure is that night that he's
brought out because that black knight
has come out it gets in the way of the
pawn and often you want to use the pawn
behind the knight to either secure your
center or or to play a bit more
aggressively and attack white center
which he can't do now so it's a
different setup but obviously being
prepared because he's played it
immediately
he's actually
just checking the database he's actually
played it before jordan has he played it
in a blitz
blitz game against uh gatakomsky
a famous grandmaster from the usa
yeah and meanwhile both sides did
develop their bishops and white has
castled the king so um
jordan maybe having predicted this
because magnus did set up set up this
way twice against him in vikanze in
january over the board and he also set
up this way against him in the tour
earlier this season so jordan not
surprised but he's surprising magnus wow
and uh i've actually every time i face
jordan i set up like this against him
with white because he's such a fearsome
attacking player and here white's king
is so safe it's unlikely he can
checkmate you at least and air things
telling us that the air quality inside
the also esports arena is very good
the temperature is
nice 23 degrees celsius but magnus has
actually put on
his coat
so does that mean that he is still a
little bit sick and not feeling very
well yeah for viewers who have followed
the tour in the past we've seen on his
athens device normally when he's at home
he likes it warm he likes it 26 degrees
and upwards
so maybe not feeling great but also
maybe just a personal preference that's
true
okay magnus meanwhile just pushing upon
his kind of uh
yeah a bit of symmetry here he wants to
fianchetto whose other bishop
potentially
put that one on the longest diagonal
yeah and i guess we're going to have a
quite a maneuvering game uh which should
suit magnus quite well all the pieces
remain on the board he's just getting
his pieces out
get into the middle game and then he's
going to try to do his magic there uh
possibly taking advantage as as i
mentioned of that black knight that came
out early could be misplaced in quite a
lot of positions
and uh meanwhile jordan just bringing
his rook across that last one's a bit
mysterious uh maybe black can use his
pawn in front of that black rook and
push it to the towards the center later
but that's not really an immediate
threat
uh so okay magnus slightly frowning just
uh coming up with a plan here will white
push a pawn will white develop the
queenside night the night's still asleep
magnus just doesn't look comfortable and
in his interview were you guys surprised
uh when svara asked are you feeling
ready he said no yeah it's rare to hear
that kind of thing from the world
champion
yeah that's true actually but normally
you say those type of things anyhow when
someone goes you know just to kind of
give yourself
that little pass in case things go wrong
but uh yeah normally that we hear the
world champion saying i am the best
but uh okay well we does seem a little
off maybe yeah yeah maybe and uh anyhow
well jordan is playing in a very very
committal style he's now exploding open
everything in the center and look at
magnus's body language he just kind of
put his head on his own shoulder right
there um
i've got to say either this is great
preparation from jordan van furist or
it's just a big bluff because black is
sacrificed to pawn temporarily the
evaluation bar really not liking it for
black and we have to jump in to show
what's happening here it looks like
jordan he's about to solve all of his
problems unless magnus gets greedy and
takes his pawn and he's got to take it
right
i'm assuming he'll take with his knight
just to open up this bishop and to
create another square that was
previously occupied for this night and
after we see a trade jordan's idea is
surely to jump forward with the black
knight and uh hitting this pawn in the
center this pawn is pinned after all it
cannot move um whoops me and my arrows
there i heard this pawn is pinned along
this diagonal and uh actually there's no
way to save it if you march this pawn
forward to protect it to create this
nice little chain then suddenly you
leave a weakness on this square and you
walk into a fork a double attack and
actually we're headed towards this
position this is the current position
black's knight has indeed jumped forward
but here what happens if white for
example brings the knight over to defend
this pawn in the center um i think i've
seen something very similar to this
before not this exact position but now
if we do see a bunch of trades uh in the
middle of the board seeing everything
come off the board then white does
eventually have ideas such as pushing
this pawn forward maybe even pushing
this pawn forward
destabilizing the black rook in order to
try and win this pawn later on um some
definite ideas here for magnus jordan
surely has prepared this position before
yeah
he must have done with his time because
he's actually up on time um and
i guess he's got confidence in holding
this position uh only needing a draw
he's got lots of pieces off the board i
think the continuation you mentioned
david is
certainly the most logical continuation
but
i mean it would seem to me that this is
also a magnus position and magnus has no
weaknesses and that pawn on the analysis
board in the middle could be a real real
problem in the long run uh with white
being able to pressurize that it's a
little bit too extended even in some
situations so um
will we see this and if so
will jordan be able to hold the position
yeah it's all about whether that pawn is
a weakness long term so in the current
position we're expecting this move from
magnus bringing the knight over uh to
defend this pawn and even if there are
trades uh then still a lot of life left
it's all about whether magnus can seize
the moment and do something over the
next few moves before jordan really gets
comfortable as black magnus is not too
used with being in must-win situations
right
i mean he's normally in the lead yeah
usually he's in the lead but we have
seen some amazing comebacks by magnus i
can remember i think it was the ftx cup
i want to say that
he won eight times
on demand and i think he's the only
player to have ever won
i mean
like this i mean because he
there have been a few finals against
wesley so where he needed to win uh just
to stay in it and sometimes he didn't
manage but sometimes he did yeah and uh
yeah i mean if anyone's capable of
winning with white in a must-win
situation it is magnus but it's not easy
for anyone at this level
yeah i remember his his dad i talked to
his dad henry carlson once and he said
you know
people are just expecting magnus to win
and even to just play a draw on demand
at this level it's actually
very hard obviously you're you're forced
to not make any mistakes and the
opponent has a say in it too so if the
opponent plays well there's
there's no guarantee you can win often
you do depend on a mistake and okay the
move we expected on the board
um there wouldn't wasn't too many uh
other options there white's night coming
to protect the pawn in the center there
was a very famous interview where magnus
lost his tamper
and the interviewer kind of said well i
wasn't so smooth for you and magnus said
well what do you want from me do you
what do you want me to just play like a
novelty and then i just win the game as
easily as that no that's not life and
that's not what chess is about chess is
sometimes a real scrap between two
players there's mistakes on both sides
and uh it's a fight and uh the game is
following the analysis that david showed
yeah so very logical play by both sides
and this is the key moment i think if
black gets one move or maybe two more
moves if black can defend that central
pawn that we highlighted a few moments
ago then black should be fine right or
at least
in a pretty safe position
temporarily but yeah it's kind of
there's a couple of options there i mean
you can attack that pawn either we will
see porno report immediately um i mean
the slower approach
maybe gives magnus something to play
against in the long run if he can still
break but um but yeah black black's
black solid he's only okay so magnus has
gone for the more aggressive idea and i
i feel in in a must-win situation
it makes sense to to attack the center
as quickly as you can yeah and i'm going
to put it to this question to both of
you but also to our twitter audience do
you think magnus will be able to make a
comeback judging from this position
simon all our viewers what do you think
i will do it i will say
flip a coin again no no you have to
commit yourself to the decision to
commit
well it is magnus
um
yes yes okay and now david now david has
to say no probably
no i'll let you go first okay yeah
the opposite to whatever david said
because it makes a bit more interesting
that's how close i always my decisions
guys agree yeah yeah
disagreement is disagreement
and uh yeah tweet us what do you think
do you think magnus will be able to make
this comeback and as always we really
love so what do you think where you
watch the selfies wait test how i said
tweet tweet us using hashtag chess
champs what do i think yeah looking at
this position i'm gonna slide with you
simon i think he's gonna do it so right
it's just the body language feels a bit
off he spent a long time up to this
point magnus uh he spent around a third
of his time already uh down to ten
minutes jordan okay i'm surprised jordan
is thinking i was gonna say we'll learn
a lot by the speed of jordan's next few
moves but
it feels like jordan
this is not the type of position you go
into as black where it's very one-sided
you're just playing for the draw
unless you know everything everything
there is to know unless you have studied
all the small details um i do know that
in
in some
kind of chats with other players they
have mentioned that jordan he's so
creative has so many ideas but sometimes
maybe forgets the tiny little
details here and there doesn't double
check things as much as the other top
players um i think they said this on the
chess 24 video series with uh peter
heiner nielsen um lauren fresonet and
jan gustafsson the kind of team behind
magnus they said jordan so creative
comes up with everything but
they need to double check his analysis
and that could be the case here because
he's paused and for two minutes now in a
very
natural move uh from magnus he should
know what to do here as black otherwise
you're just going to lose a pawn black's
pawn in the center under fire and not so
easy to protect it's quite i mean the
movie you'd like to play it's just to
defend it with your bishop
to bring bring a piece out defend it
hopefully more exchanges happen but that
just runs into
a pawn push um which attacks the rook so
i i i don't think you can play this
natural move because after this one we
see the prague rook don't we uh the
pragmatic prague
rook and um it doesn't have a good
square so uh um i don't believe any
exchange sacrifice sacrifices work here
so uh so you can't you can't play the
natural defensive move
the other problem david i'm sure is if
you push the pawn on well now you get a
real imbalance and structure and again
this same push could be very annoying i
mean black's king is a real target and
the pawn the black pawn in the middle is
a bit of a weakness so it's not it
doesn't seem straightforward to know
what the answer is to to magnus's move
actually yeah and
magnus's last move just to highlight it
once more pushing this pawn forward it
does create some tension here as
mentioned the pawn cannot be captured
because the black queen is actually
undefended so the black pawn is pinned
and
yeah you have to surely if you want to
play this opening you have to know what
to do against the obvious move like
magnus is threatening to take this pawn
uh what is jordan thinking about i think
he might well push on but uh probably
has to push on i mean i i don't think
he's got really any other option i mean
you don't want to defend the pawn of
your pawn i mean you're just going to be
a lot well i say a lot worse but you're
going to be in a horrible position
against uh uh the best player in the
world in such structures yeah isolated
pawn here would just be terribly weak
this white bishop as well attacking it
permanently so jordan has indeed chosen
the other option he's pushed on and
magnus is going to try and destabilize
this pawn first remember this pawn still
pinned
along the d line uh so now you just have
to protect it you can't continue pushing
this pawn it will just go too far behind
enemy lines so you have to protect it
and we see a quick trade and we'll see
jordan recapture this pawn surely with
his own pawn and it's about whether this
isolated pawn now is a weakness as well
i like simon's idea of pushing forward
kicking back the black rook and creating
this really nice pawn chain also this
white bishop coming to life on the
diagonal still not 100 clear but
imbalanced enough for magnus to try and
create some winning chances
yeah i have to say i love love that uh
porn
pattern that you sent
well you showed
and uh
i liked what you said about pawns like
they they need friends
i'm going to remember that now they need
friends to hold hands they need support
when they go out the board
generally yeah
much nicer than saying porn chains
yeah
that's like a bike chain isn't it
exactly yeah that sounds a bit boring
friends
sounds a bit more like friends friends
yeah that's what i would say
in between us if you're not sure where
that came from great tv program that's a
fantastic tv program
oh yeah meanwhile jordan's last move the
speed with which he played it means that
maybe he's still in preparation maybe
he's studied this before or just needed
a few minutes to recall what he'd looked
at because black's last move does look a
bit weird yes the black rook's on an
open file now the c file but it doesn't
help to protect
this pawn in the center that magnus is
going for look on magnus's screen he's
about to bring his rook behind his queen
lining up against black's pawn the
isolated pawn in the center of the board
that pawn is doomed
no way to save it now you just have to
look for tricks with black and maybe
evaluation bar liking black's position
suddenly but do you think this could be
a case of like a little bit of bluff
from jordan that he's seen this position
he's going to whip his bishop out to
like e6 and he knows that the ending
after a lot of whipping off there's a
lot of whipping saying we don't know why
i'm doing that but
he knows that the ending is going to
lead to what the position is going to
lead to equal ending and he's just sort
of slowing down because sometimes if
you know you might have analyzed
something and to kind of double trick
your opponent you don't want to rush the
moves out because your opponent smells a
rat you want to sort of slow it down a
little bit and just sort of you know get
him into the position you want is that
possible here it's possible um that's
the type of thing i notice a lot of
young people do i used to do it when i
was younger myself you pretend you have
no idea what's going on and then
suddenly once you've lured your opponent
in like you said suddenly bang bang bang
bang bang you show them you know
the next few moves the plan going
forward but he's paused again jordan
i've done that when uh i've set a trap
a prepared trap you know i'm like
well when i was a kid not now i don't do
those kind of things anything like look
behind you like
yeah i've never seen this position
before and then then when they play it's
like yeah you kind of like immediately
sit up and you're like oh you've fallen
for something bad um yeah jordan uh
developing the light square bishop
yeah so white can go one point up
white's queen can just zoom up the board
two squares grab black sex uh isolated
pawn in the center and
white will be a pawn up but that end
game as simon mentioned black is very
active in that in game suddenly black's
rook on the c file on an open line
not clear at all whether magnus will
have enough firepower left to win that
one
so i'm expecting him to grab the pawn to
take the pawn because
why not why not go upper material and at
least have something to hold on to for
later
but a long long way to go before magnus
can dream of turning this one into a win
jordan meanwhile looking very calm very
relaxed
and uh yeah it'll be interesting that's
the one difference i think with esports
and over-the-board chess it's harder to
bluff your opponent maybe in the esport
arena especially with no time on the
clock in long chess you can kind of sit
back you have two hours you can say oh
yeah i'm pretending not to know what's
going on you can especially as a kid
gesture a bit i think we've all
mentioned you do these things more as a
kid don't you like
for some reason you're like oh no
blunted my queen they take the queen
you're like chippy
it doesn't really work when you get
older it does it then he'll do that
bring it back here you've caught me out
again
oh no you know the biggest like yeah
i remember one kid telling me well his
opponent had a mate in two but his
opponent decided to have some fun and
deliver mate in three you know because
he had all the time in the world so the
kid just said you know what if he's not
gonna checkmate me immediately i'm gonna
wait until my clock runs down all 45
minutes of it
and his parents were like talking to me
and saying oh my god what can we do
the kid was adamant no no you know i'm
going to make so many ways i mean what's
the funniest thing you've done as a kid
i mean i remember
there's loads that i've done but we
won't go there i mean i remember one day
when uh i was really young and um i
offered my opponent a draw i was like
eight years old and he said yeah and i
go and i said actually i've changed my
mind
and then he and then he burst out crying
and uh yeah i was only eight he was
eight no you know
both eight years old if it was an
adult funny
and then he called the arbiter over and
i was like oh i thought i'd actually
play on and i said
it's like okay i'll take the trick
yeah just burst out crying i'm like that
that happened to me once as well i
offered a draw and i thought it was
perpetual check but it was painting as
an adult so i was maybe 12 years old at
the time
and
he he kind of said no he'd like to play
on
and then i was so happy when he said no
because i just realized i actually had
more than perpetual check i checked mate
and then you know i made my move and he
goes oh yeah it's a draw isn't it and
then he tries to stop the clock and i'm
like no no no it was a one-time offer
play play play and i felt bit bad
because it wasn't adult and i was like
this pretentious kid and then you won
the game right yeah of course i won the
game i think it was my only point in the
tournament but yeah
exactly yeah absolutely i mean back to
the game david i mean it looks like uh
you know black has a lot of pressure is
he going to win the pawn back i mean if
he does then it's
looking fine for jordan yeah i think
jordan's done a great job so the queens
did come off white is one pawn up but
this last move by black extremely clever
maybe magnus missed this one because now
jordan looks destined to simon says to
win his pawn back and how is magnus
gonna even keep his winning chances
alive maybe magnus this is the key
moment uh because if he doesn't find
something now he's losing his pawn this
is a pin after all and uh if white does
nothing for example if white pushes a
pawn forward then black can play bishop
takes pawn utilizing the fact that this
white pawn is pinned uh if you take this
bishop then the white rook drops behind
that pawn and suddenly whoops also a pin
on this file so uh yeah it's looking
scary this is a big threat bishop takes
pawn you can't prevent it in many ways
you don't really want to put your white
rook on a bad square because okay you're
attacking a pawn but after black removes
that threat this rook is stuck this rook
is stuck both defending pawns and
no way forward black has an easy inroads
as well into your position the black
rook if it finds itself on the second
rank will lead
to a great position now
jordan here would be very very happy
magnus reluctant to put his rock on a
bad square but otherwise do you have to
trade off bishops but now you give
yourself a bad pawn structure as well
these pawns are weak this pawn is weak
to isolate isolated pawns there
looking good for black to be honest
looks like black should be pretty safe
and i'm struggling to see a movie even
simon uh it's all about this threat and
how do you stop it not just that one
actually but also the black rook coming
in
yeah no i i agree and he's also
magnus tank tanked quite a lot of time
here uh probably realizing that um yeah
you know some great prep i feel from
jordan actually and he sort of uh
recalled his you know recall what he was
memorizing and he's probably just
thinking now how do i get it's pro okay
i'm equal but how do i get a position
which has some imbalance in it because
even if it's equal i need to unbalance
position how do i do that and
well i can't i can't really see how he
does it at the moment to be honest it's
only bishops on the board with level
pawns it's a draw if it's only rooks on
the board with level pawns it's a draw
magnus's margin for error here is tiny
and okay he decides to push this pawn
forward um this is one that we didn't
consider because it looks like black is
about to take a pawn now with the black
bishop and magnus did he just react
there did he yawn or did he say
something to himself either way i think
black is completely fine there we go
that pawn drops so now level material on
the board this is magnus's idea but
i don't think it's going to get anywhere
lisa's sort of uh again unbalanced the
pawn structure at least because he's got
a majority on the king side against his
opponent's majority on the queen side
shouldn't be enough um i but
um i mean can he win the pawn on b7 now
or does black just play
bishop to to some square like c2 here
yeah he can also or brooks yeah bishops
yeah move the bishop and also maybe
develop defend the uh
the pawn
so there are some small traps in the
position um you guys are discussing a
few moves there so
this bishop attacked this pawn also
attacked double attack there and you
want to deal with both of them if you
defend your bishop with your rook then
actually that loses on the spot because
this again it's all about the pins and
this bishop is now pinned on the third
rank you can't move the bishop because
the rook behind it will fall
so this bishop now will drop
so that would be a losing blunder for
jordan if you drop back your bishop then
suddenly white does have a small
advantage because white can take a pawn
back
with a nice active rook now white's a
pawn up again so maybe the move is this
one but you have to calculate well
because this also walks into a pin it's
all about the pins in this game and
suddenly the black bishop can't move
because of the tension on this file you
have to be super careful here
if you're careless and just push your
pawn forward then i think white is gonna
win by bringing the bishop forward and
uh okay we might be headed in this
direction suddenly you break the
connection between black's rook and
black's bishop with your own bishop here
and if the black bishop jumps out the
way then bishop takes pawn check is
deadly winning the black rook at the end
coming out with a rook versus bishop
advantage wow magnus didn't go for this
i i'm shocked um i thought this was the
only way to keep the game going because
now after bishop takes pawn
it's level material and look how
symmetrical it is uh the position now
dead draw
i think
how are you ever going to win this guy
this game now okay he offers a trade of
rooks
oh this is magnus's idea but even if you
trade even if you give black uh give
white sorry everything he wants uh
attacking this porn you can just defend
with your rook and this should still be
a draw
a little bit of hard work to be done
there by jordan but
he should hold this one now getting
close to a match win um has he has he
won a lot against magnus before jordan
will this be a huge moment basically for
him yeah definitely yeah um he's uh well
borrowing the win from earlier on today
he's never won a game actually against
really yeah i mean he lost one game and
then there was a whole series of draws
but of course
being his second and uh
i think they were joking that jordan was
magnus's punching bag
in terms of online and not online chess
blitz chess yeah you know trying out
ideas
and uh they played a lot of blitz chess
in the run-up to the world championship
match as training um he was a bit of a
sparring partner for magnuson
yeah i i shouldn't give away my source
but i heard that the score was very
one-sided so this is going to be a big
breakthrough for jordan wow
that is very cool he is only uh 22 i
think yeah jordan fun for east a very
young chess player with a bright chess
future ahead of him and this is going to
be
a big moment in his career if he is able
to hold the draw in this game
and win the match winning one game
it's looking bad for magnus to get that
win that he needs i guess yeah if anyone
can squeeze blood blood out of a stone
it is magnus carlsen especially in an
endgame like this one he is an end game
expert after all white has a small tiny
tiny little advantage because white has
a target black's pawn on the left side
very very weak and black's rook stuck
defending it and also white's king is
closer to the center now
but uh it shouldn't really be enough
it's hard to imagine a winning plan here
no i mean um if if jordan could exchange
both pawns on the queen side uh that'd
be just dead completely dead so i'm
wondering if somehow he can try to
liquidate and do that so i don't think
it's so easy but maybe with the bishop
coming back to attack white's pawn
and then uh putting more pressure on it
with the rook could help him but yeah i
mean the white king's now coming towards
the center
and white has a slightly easier position
to play so it's not it's not over
there's played left in this position and
i i i wouldn't want to defend this
position against uh
extremely strong player i think it'd
still be tough
yeah and uh we could also see from a lot
of the tweets that were shown on the
screen that a lot of people believed in
uh magnus's ability to win and they were
saying that he looks actually much much
better today than he did yesterday
yep yep uh magnus at least this this is
the type of position that he can play on
forever right uh you can play 50 moves
60 moves 70 moves higher out your
opponent's your favorite 100 180
grind like a grand
that's quite an interesting name for a
course david you get the inspiration for
that for your own games oh that's a nice
gesture yeah yeah from my own games any
other grand masters yeah lots of
grandmasters like grinding don't they
borrow a scale fan the ultimate grinder
especially in engage like this one yeah
it's engraving also a type of dance so
you're going to have a little gif then
as you're kind of covered
on the chessboard
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa we're tearing down the studio
destroy like a grandmaster
a wheel just came off
that happened to me
you guys to calm down
now davis says grind like a grandmaster
that's exciting the same game is yeah
yeah
and black advancing and pawn forward on
the right and
well magnus developing his bishop
improving it and uh well we did ask for
memes and uh well eric janssen
did deliver
because he shows a picture of coulson
dressed for his game against van
freeze oh that's quite clever very good
nice one
very very very very good eric and
female nurse she references
david's
hulk moments
[Laughter]
yeah meanwhile a move a couple of moves
no real progress for magnus but he's
about to start pushing his pawns on the
king side on this right half of the
board
i can't imagine him winning this one
simon you just uh you you've reacted to
that one though
when you go passive it's always a bit
makes it tough and um yeah i can see
it's obviously instead of draw but i
think jordan's now gone for the policy
of just sitting there he's literally
just gonna sit here keep his pieces
where they are and hope magnus can't
make progress and it's a dangerous
policy that one uh there's no way
maggots can get through uh jordan's gone
back but don't know still still uh i've
just seen magnus do magic in so many
positions like this he does grind like a
grand master he really does the ultimate
grinder yeah you and him you're the
grinding posse i mean dave i say david's
a grinder because of his moves on like
uh
now because of his games is long games
and uh you two are phenomenal at getting
bloodhouses for staying well magnus did
kind of dedicate his uh game six super
long grinding win in the world
championship match to david
being so inspired by those long games
but you know i do think david takes it
to the next level
i have nothing better to do than sort of
the chessboard
you love it so much i really do there's
something wrong with me i don't know why
i can't explain it
who is your biggest inspiration david
where where did you get this grinding
style from i think maybe it's because i
had some books about capablanca about
karpov when i was young i played through
some games with ulf anderson and other
great end-game expert and i just found
beauty and those tiny little kind of
tricks that they set or their patience
and their stamina and i treat it like a
sport sometimes you just have to tire
out your opponent yeah i know that when
i play these guys i'm not better than
them but maybe i have more energy or
more kind of
yeah maybe
yeah stamina keep the games going for
longer so
that's the strategy and uh if magnus
wins this game it will go down in i
think his top 10 end game grinds so
could make it in any year
any books he does in the future or
something yeah or anything
courses possibly yeah he's made some
progress he's forced the black king
backwards now trading a set of pawns
that's not great long term you don't
want to trade off too many pawns but you
have to in order to push forward and
magnus taking over some territory and
win and draw oh sorry los angeles is uh
the same for magnus he has to win this
game to take it to tie breaks yeah and
there we go jordan just making life as
difficult as possible for the world
champion it's not easy to grind this one
out because the white rook no matter
where it goes will continue to get hit
and uh it can't sit on this dream square
the white rook where it puts pressure on
a pawn and kind of cuts on uh cuts off
the sixth rank because it gets kicked
away by the black bishop i guess one of
the key moves that i i see that black's
played so far is where jordan has
positioned his rook i think that's
extremely clever uh cutting the white
king off you can see where the rook is
the black rook it just stops white's
king coming towards uh the queen side
magnus would love to lift his king up
and place it somewhere else maybe all
the way over on the queen side but he
just can't do that so it is very hard to
make progress i mean if he he can't
really exchange too many more pawns
so what how does he actually do anything
here that's the big question for magnus
if you can play around for the next 50
60 moves i want this to go over 100
moves i don't think it qualifies as a
proper end game unless you get over 100
moves but uh yeah either way
actually making that final step setting
a trap that's the hard part so a title
for a book could be my greatest well the
greatest plus 100 games
you can you know just
but the best thing is simon is that we
should get david to annotate every
single one of those moves
[Music]
definitely that will teach you exactly
no more long games you will never grind
out an end game again after that i'll do
my best 20 move wins and you do your
best 100 plus wins my book will be
bigger longer because
oh
and uh well magnus are
much forward with the f pawn and that of
course initiated a trade
it seemed like the only way to make
progress
but somehow you know trading pawns
takes jordan that one step closer to the
draw having said that there's a big
threat in the air
well the king and the rook they can be
forked if the white pawn reaches f6
square so you need to defend against
that that's a deadly check incoming from
white's pawn so you need to either block
the advance of that pawn with your own
pawn but then maybe giving away control
of some important squares or you need to
run away with the black rook or with a
black king
you can't move your bishop right now you
have to do something about that white
pawn stepping forward one more square
but if you can trade off one more set of
pawns it's basically guaranteed to be a
draw now
magnus not messing around he's creating
the threats but jordan's stopping them
at every turn and this uh final must-win
game for minus started at exactly the
same time as his favorite football team
real madrid semi-final against
manchester city and it's going horribly
wrong for real madrid as well
well actually there they just scored a
goal
wow well but they are down two uh one to
manchester city so marines will not be
too happy when he sees that as well
can't believe you're watching the
football
[Laughter]
too much drama happening in the also
esports arena today to watch anything
else
yeah but magnus i mean if he ends up not
winning this game he'll be rushing off
to watch that football match for sure
um it gets him inspired we've seen that
before in the tour last season he loves
his football yeah he does and magnus of
course needing to go for the kill and uh
richard harding on twitter shares a
selfie with his two grand gm
grandchildren go also going for the kill
children yeah
potential grand masters ah
cool yeah yeah i like to see it when a
boy and a girl playing yeah future
generation inspired absolutely very cool
let's hope to see those two in a world
championship match in uh what would that
be 20 years maybe
oh no no no in this day and age kyle it
would be like
10 years
with what pregnant's doing exactly
20 30 a next world championship yeah
just get younger and younger i was just
how
how young do you think the next grand
master will be you know it's what's the
record at the moment 12 years old
12 years in a few months
can someone be 11 years old and be a
grammar it's only a matter of time
probably isn't it i mean prague became
an international master at 10 years old
and also um
what's his name
ambi manu thank you abhimanyu mishra the
youngest it was during covent and now
that the kids can play a lot more
yeah yeah might be a younger one coming
yeah they have better and better
resources their chess engines are
getting better so they can train better
and of course there's like um the chess
community is growing so there's more
grand masters and of course now the
internet has opened up everything and
made
absolutely everything so much easier
yeah
yeah who will be the next grand youngest
grandmaster who will be the next world
champion if magnus carlsen decides to uh
walk away from his title
jordan phan for east could he be a
future world champion it's possible he's
young enough he's
still only 22 but
yeah he'll need
luck on his side of course there are so
many players in this generation whoever
becomes world champion will need luck
need things going in their favor i don't
think we'll see an era of dominance like
we have from kasparov from carlson now i
don't think we'll see that for a while i
think we're going to see lots and lots
of different players fighting for the
title all similar strength
um events we see
do you think at the top it's become it's
become closer like if you go back to the
days of kasparov he had quite a
significant
advantage over other players as you
could say magnus does as well to be fair
he is quite a lot better than the
players but they are kind of catching up
now and all the other players are just
so similar in strength now there's so
many of them who are just really good
and the the margins are so small i mean
that's how how strong people have become
i think really and they're just
incredibly strong yeah but in a way it's
kind of a little bit of a pity if
there's so many
grand masters kind of switching the
title backwards and forwards i mean
because we always remember the great
rivalries like you know you mentioned
kasparov you know for me i grew up on
watching his games against karpov and uh
you know it was so close so tense and
you know you you're always rooting for
your hero to to win and
that's something that you can't quite
get
if there's so many good players at the
top so i really do hope that someone
comes and starts challenging for the
crown a little bit more permanently but
we've seen that before and it was very
exciting with bob vinnick he lost his
title a few times and then he always
regained it um i mean even we talked
about mikhail tile one of the greatest
world champions he won it off bob
finnick but he lost it one year later uh
smithloff won it lost it back
so yeah still exciting no matter what
happens but okay that's for generations
to come for now we've got to focus on
the current world champion and he's
trying but not so far succeeding to win
this game jordan he's done a great thing
look how the black pawns are on dark
squares completely blockading on that
color complex
magnus with a light squared bishop can't
break through
and uh okay he's gone active with the
white rook i'm expecting maybe the black
king to start moving over now towards
the center towards that white rook
the black bishop could also move you
could maybe even give a check with the
black rook first the only thing you have
to be really be careful of here is maybe
trading a set of rooks off and allowing
white's king to make a dash for that
black pawn that lone black pawn on the
left
because then maybe white is in time but
it's hard to imagine that happening i
mean i guess there's some
checkmate nets that white could try um
you know or at least force black king to
the black king is in a bad square the
white king is in central board the black
king is a little bit boxed in
so if white can put his bishop on two
squares forwards for example then check
the king you can get the black king to
the side of the board so you can sort of
play around with some ideas but they
shouldn't they shouldn't work of course
but you know white white has got
slightly better chances of anything
slightly white's still the one playing
for the win that's for sure um but
that's why i like this last move simon
you mentioned the black king there's a
chance he would have got caught on one
side of the board so why not centralize
it if possible and now it's heading
towards that white rook
chance is disappearing jordan he's
looking a bit nervous fidgeting there
on the left but
he's played great so far defended really
really well the dutchman yeah he has uh
defended incredibly well and uh we do
have a question from chris paul colin to
david it says what is the most
satisfying endgame for you
let me think uh there's been too many
just the problem just the way you
laughed there was satisfying you know
it's like just recalling them i might
have to wait for my chestable course on
end games to find out but uh a lot of
satisfying end games
maybe one of them was beating luke
mcshane one of my kind of kryptonite
players one of my nemesis
um a few years ago in the german league
in the bundesliga in a very difficult
end game it looked very equal for a long
time but i had the two bishops against
the bishop at night and i managed to
grind him down eventually so yeah how
many moves i think it wasn't 100
unfortunately it was maybe only 70 or
80.
yeah just a light workout that day
but magnus he is playing a long game
here one game has finished here in this
round for today duda and liam le a draw
so that means we will have tie breaks
today they tied the rapid match and now
they're going to play blitz tiebreaks
duda he won his blitz tiebreak yesterday
against mom diaram so he will be feeling
confident on his birthday today as well
geary and mamadiarov as well if they
play a draw they will head to tie breaks
the bar is in the middle so maybe we
will have two tie breaks
and even three if magnus wins this game
but the bar is just not moving away from
zero no that's right and now the black
king has got active so even more
difficult here to imagine a win for
white white's rook might well go after
black pawn on the right half the f6 pawn
there we go that white rook about to
take upon but black's bishop can also
take a pawn now as well
and uh that would just be a trade not
too much to get excited about there for
white black does have the option
i was gonna say if muching his king
towards the center but maybe that's not
so uh i mean maybe that's not so
practical you don't need to get too
ambitious with the black king here i
think that maybe is fine as well but you
need to do a bit of calculation the
safest move is to pick up the black
bishop and go and grab this white pawn
yeah and there we go it happens
a porn trade and with the more pawns
that disappear the closer we can go
forwards here yeah and go forwards
don't go to the center oh we went
forwards but yeah if he went the other
way it could have been well it would
have been checkmate see
maybe we can just show this on the board
you can never relax too early uh just
one
small trick that the world champion set
for his young opponent checking the king
and as simon mentioned if you went
forward you normally want to centralize
the king but this would have ended in
checkmate you get caught
in amongst white's pieces so of course
he didn't fall for this jordan instead
he went the other way he marched this
way and uh now this black pawn whoops
sorry me and my arrows this black pawn
is about to start pushing forward
uh so both sides have a
they're going to balance each other out
and we're headed most likely towards a
draw let's go back to the players it's
uh yep desperate times now for magnus
and all his fans
yeah looks like he uh
will lose this much magnus carlsen drama
in the oslo esports got pragnanda
sitting in his hotel room he's been
there for a long time he finished after
three games today frank with a win and
he will be in seoul lead after
day five with only two days left to play
in this major
imagine if the 16 year old wins the
first major in the milton championship
2022
i know you said it david but it just uh
it's just so incredible if it happens
yeah i mean that'll be history making
groundbreaking
incredible achievement if it happens and
he's looking uh odds on now
to do it maybe who can stop prag i
wonder who's got who who he has left to
play i mean he's got some tough games i
think is it uh jan christophe judah dude
and round six dangerous yeah so
i'll just check
magnus there you can see look at that
face he's he knows he's gonna i think he
realizes he's just gonna lose lose this
match now
gary in round seven two tough matches
then for uh prague basically very tough
matches those ones
okay and magnus he repeated the position
once but remember a draw is basically
the same as a loss for him so now he's
trying everything he's pushed the white
pawn but this is a really classy move by
vampirist locking down completely the
position
black's bishop and black's rook
completely stop that white pawn from
advancing and magnus he's got to be the
one who's careful here to save the draw
he gives a check the black king can move
pretty much anywhere and nothing to be
done that black pawn is too dangerous
now you have to keep your white rook
behind it
and we will see the position repeat
itself
okay magnus still playing for the win
huh brave guy wow he might as well might
as well right loss is the same as a a
draw i guess so he doesn't care about
the tour ratings it's all about winning
the match and black's pawn two squares
away from promotion now
promise the white king anytime it goes
towards the black king it just gets
checked away by the black rook
and okay magnus stopping the pawn with
his bishop instead
clever move he's keeping the game alive
but it's hard to envisage anything going
wrong for jordan here he gives a check
maybe king c3 can even come if uh yeah
you want to try that at some point you
don't need to but
give a check he can go after white's
bishop
he'd go after white's pawn actually if
he goes after white's bishop
then the king and the rook have aligned
themselves and uh oh what's happening
really inconvenient diagonal bar just
shot up yeah um i think actually black
had a really strong move there he could
have gone after white's bishop but no we
see a trade of rooks and a draw is
almost inevitable now
nothing to be done there we go
bishop only on the board but it is a
draw it's over a win for jurgen families
in the match against
magnus crossing we did see
a congratulation i think from magnus too
you wouldn't but